بريطاني الجنسيه لكن انتماءاته متعدده
فتاره ومقاوم هولندي وتاره رجل دوله
بريطاني ثم شيوعي متزمت حالات مختلفه
عاشها قبل ان يصبح جورجي ايفانوفيتش الذي
وجد ميلاده في احضان الاتحاد السوفيتي فما
قصته ولد جورج بليك في هولندا عام
1922 لام هولنديه واب يهودي مصري يحمل
الجنسيه البريطانيه ووساما من الجيش
البريطاني لقتاله ضد الاتراك امضى جورج
طفولته بهولندا حيث امتلكت عائله والده
شركه للنسيج واراد حينها ان يصبح كاهنا
هناك لكن حلمه توقف لانه بعد وفاه والده
انتقل الى القاهره للاقامه مع اعمامه حيث
ترعرع مع ابن عمه هنري كوريل الذي اصبح
شيوعيا متزمتا بعد ان انهى دراسته
بالمدرسه الانجليزيه بالقاهره عاد جورج
الى هولندا وهناك اعجب بالمقاومه
الهولنديه واتخذ لنفسه اسما حركيا هو ماكس
ما عرضه لبعض المشكلات حيث اعتقل لفتره
وجيزه كما حارب مع المقاومه الهولنديه
خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه عند بلوغه سن
الثامنه عشره هرب متنكرا بزي راهب وعبر
فرنسا واسبانيا وجبل طارق لينضم الى
والدته وشقيقاته في بريطانيا وهناك اتخذ
سمابليك والتحق بالبحريه البريطانيه حيث
عمل بتشغيل الغواصات الصغيره
في عام
1944 وبفضل مهاراته اللغويه المتعدده جند
بلاك لدى المخابرات البريطانيه السريه ام
اي 6 وعمل بالقسم الهولندي خدم بليك بعدها
لفتره وجيزه بمدينه هامبورغ الالمانيه
ودرس اللغه الروسيه في جامعه كامبريدج قبل
ارساله الى كوريا الشماليه في عام
1948 لجمع معلومات استخباريه عنها وعن
الصين الشيوعيه والسوفييت
الحرب الكوريه في عام 1950 قبضت عليه قوه
كوريا الشماليه ليمكث في السجن ثلاث سنوات
انشغل خلالها باكمال قراءاته لاعمال كارل
ماركس وفيما تنامت لديه مشاعر الغضب ازاء
القصف الامريكي العنيف على كوريا الشماليه
تحول العميل البريطاني الى شيوعي متزمت
ويعتقد انه في تلك الفتره بدا العمل لصالح
السوفييت
بعد عامين من الافراج عنه عاد بليك
لبريطانيا لتعيد ارساله الى برلين مع مهمه
لجمع معلومات عن جواسيس السوفيتي والمانيا
الشرقيه وتجنيد عملاء مزدوجين لكن ما فعله
كان تزويد السوفييت بمعلومات خطيره
احدى العمليات التي اخبرهم عنها كانت ما
عرف بعمليه الذهب حيث استخدمت المخابرات
البريطانيه نفقا سريا في المانيا الشرقيه
لاعتراض الاتصالات العسكريه لسوفييت
والمانيا الشرقيه كما كشف للسوفييت عن
اكثر من 400 عميل مزدوج حسب اعترافه في
كتابه
تم الكشف عن بليك من قبل المنشق السوفيتي
مايكل في عام
1961 فحكم عليه بالسجن لمده 42 عاما لكنه
هرب من السجن بمساعده ثلاثه مساجين اخرين
قبل ان يتم تهريبه الى برلين الشرقيه
ومنها للاتحاد السوفيتي وروسيا في روسيا
اتخذ اسم جورجي ايفانوفيتش وتزوج سيده
الروسيه بعد ان طلق زوجته جيليان الان
التي كان السكرتيره بالمخابرات السريه كما
عمل بمعهد للشؤون الخارجيه ثم حصل على
تكريم من بوتين ورتبه مقدم بالكي جي بي
وراتب تقاعدي
حتى وفاته عام 2020 وفي سنواته الاخيره
التي امضاها بمنزل ريفي خارج موسكو لم
يتردد في الكشف عن كونه يعيش حاله من
السعاده لانه قدم الخدمات لروسيا وخان
بلاده